[Music]
oh good you're awake
come speak
zemerik is pleased to see you are awake
you have slept for many days and this
one feared the worst
we both were the caravan that brought us
to northern elsewhere was attacked by
the Great Beast luckily the adepts of
star Haven witnessed a humble adept
nothing more this one was exiled from
his home long ago but felt the time had
come for him to return that is not a
tale that Sam Urick wishes to tell not
right now
besides the Grand adapt wants to talk
with you best not to keep greetings
this one is Majid ro Grand adapt of star
Haven he is glad to see you in good
health traveller it is not every day
that one survives a dragon attack bright
moons must have blessed your path you
were carrying the letter when we found
you it looked important so we left it
where you could find it but how do you
feel traveller let us test your strength
then yes though this one is now grant
adapt not here of course this is not
ever an bra collect a training sword and
meet this one outside the gardens take
up one of our training swords and meet
this one in the gardens
hmm this guy's warned of a changing
season can you see it
modular Oh can think of no better let us
begin my chakra very solid 5 leaked work
you strike well but can you guard
now look swing strike well this one is
off balance what a powerful blow again
break with force traffic brutal heat
shield yourself and once more such
masterful strikes but what if you are in
distress now great free that this one's
trap here comes another trap
it's ready for another again press your
advantage with a heavy attack quickly
now stop these one strike
I guess stop this one's attack your
enemy charges their assault strike
interrupt their attack and punish the
recitation student the game come now the
discontinued you the auditorium
wait did you hear that you must help the
other atoms take the passage through the
catacombs this one must go ones Amarok
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank John George you arrived
well it looks like you've certainly
recovered from your wounds and the
soldiers said they were searching for
something but they barely gave us an
itch yes this one heard it's terrible
voice like something out of a moon
singers atop that power seats the dragon
horn said to ground dragons with one
mighty call Bowie shadi is not sure if
the legends are true
it is our best hope against then you
must exit the catacombs and follow the
path north there you will see the tower
this one cannot
[Music]
even dragons
[Music]
[Music]
nothing but old phones here what a waste
of my time
I say we bring the whole place to the
ground
[Music]
the dragon may be subdued but not for
long
this one feels for those inside the
auditorium then zemerik and the
traveller will go you should take this
chance to escape
so return to my let us leave this place
before the beast returns why did the
dragon flee
it was called away this one heard its
name on the wind below kadam called away
to the Dragons work together perhaps at
the very least this dragon seems to have
allied himself with the Europeans then
the rebellion has begun yes this one is
afraid it has come traveller let us
speak thank you for saving Machado rose
disciples you have a courageous spirit
it will do you well should you decide to
stay in elsewhere and this one does hope
you decide to stay the Khajiit need
heroes like you during these dark times
and only more to come this one fears
before you leave you should speak to
Zama Rock it seems that he's also
decided to leave us